uh a pioneer in uh the role of dynamics
and coding in uh memory and reasoning
very happy to have ila here today
presenting to us she was also a
participant in that uh
brain and computation program
uh that bruno mentioned earlier ela
welcome
oh thank you so much peter uh let me
share my screen uh
it is wonderful to be here
uh
just make sure you can see this are you
able to
see the presentation
yes we are
okay fantastic well first of all
congratulations uh to the simon's
institute community at large
on the 10th anniversary it was a real
pleasure to be there in 2018 um that's
part of the program that uh bruno
organized uh and uh congratulations
especially to shafi and peter so um and
uh i guess i have benefited from jim
simon's support of
both uh you know mathematical
neuroscience neuroscience and computer
science in all of his different
uh modes of philanthropy and setting up
this institute as well as setting up
various funding mechanisms
for neuroscience and mathematical
neuroscience so
i'm very very pleased to be able to give
this talk and i regret not being there
um i have a family event
which keeps me away so
without further ado i want to tell you a
little bit following up on the things
that bruno talked about um i want to
tell you about some of the remarkable uh
computations that the brain does in the
context of
spatial navigation uh and also actually
turns out that the
underpinnings of spatial navigation in
the brain are then
repurposed and reused by the brain to do
other kinds of mapping of the world more
generally so hopefully i'll have a
chance to tell you that as well all
right so um let's uh just start with a
bit of a
visual outline of where we're gonna go
so the first question is why are we
particularly interested in um spatial
navigation why should this be of
interest to you as computer scientists
the second question is um that uh you
know what are the neural circuits that
support
these kinds of computations where do
they reside in the brain
uh the next question is what are the
underlying representations and codes and
dynamics that allow the brain to do
these computations next we'll discuss
some of the properties of these codes
the brain has a lot of flexibility in
choosing how to represent information
why does it choose these particular
representations
and then finally we'll talk about how
these kinds of
circuits in the brain can inform us in
building
architectures in computer science and
machine learning and also to just better
understand
you know dynamical properties that go
beyond just spatial navigation
so all right so um the first thing i
want to point out is that again part of
the bigger theme here is that um you
know the brain certainly encodes for
space and space is an interesting
problem um in its own right but it turns
out that space is also a rather
privileged variable and a rather
privileged thing uh that the brain
represents and and it seems to have
these inductive biases towards
interpreting the world in in some
spatial terms so here is an old
experiment done by um tolman uh one of
the behavioral psychologists you know
from the early 1900s and he trained
animals on um two flavors of a task in
the same apparatus the first was a
response task and in the response task
um the animal would um uh you know be
trained to uh turn left uh whenever it
was released from one of the arms uh to
retrieve cheese so if it went from the
south arm it would have to turn left and
then it would get a reward and if it
went from the north arm it would turn
left and then again get a reward um on
the other hand there was a version of
the task called the place task in which
the location of the reward was fixed in
a spatial sense and what the animal had
to do is it had to think about what that
location was and how to get to it um
and and take action flexibly to be able
to get to that location and retrieve the
reward and so in this case coming from
the south arm the animal would turn left
but coming from the north arm the animal
will have to turn right um and what
tillman found is that there was
substantially faster learning on the
place task than on the simple um
response task would suggest an
evolutionary bias towards learning
spatial maps over learning procedures
and this was especially notable in those
days because that was the time when um
behaviors behavioral
behaviorism was ascendant and the idea
was that a lot of learning in biological
organisms was of the of the variety of
like um you know action reward
association learning so in other words
um basic reinforcement learning what we
call policy uh learning um but here
animals seem to exhibit
a preference for understanding the world
in a spatial context
uh the next example uh
the next thing that i want to tell you
about about you know why we should study
navigation so the first one is to say
navigation is important its own right
but also it seems to have a privileged
role in how we organize our
understanding of the world but the
second thing is to say that you know
spatial navigation is a hard problem in
its own right and because it's so hard
it's led to a lot of innovations in um
in um
in uh in uh
in in solving these difficult problems
and uh these innovations have of course
been in the realm of human technology
technological innovations that we have
driven to be able to solve our own
navigation problems but at the same time
also neural circuits in the brain have
um made a lot of technological
innovations on their own to be able to
solve very difficult navigation problems
so this is the um fortuitously the same
example that bruno just showed you this
is that cataglyphus fortis ant in the
moroccan desert it does these um 500
meter long meandering trajectories
looking for food and then taking
straight b-line paths all the way back
suggesting that this
you know simple small animal is capable
of doing two-dimensional um vector
integration so um these are the kinds of
feats i mean i could go on i could spend
you know hours talking about the various
different navigational feats that
animals are capable of so um hopefully
this gives you enough motivation to um
to to be curious about um what it is
that the brain uh uh does um uh in in
being able to solve these problems right
so one thing i i should just mention is
up here our technological innovations
include things like gps today which
involve you know satellites and rockets
and all that but here uh biological
organisms must make do with their brains
okay so what are these um neural
substrates for uh spatial navigation so
this on the left is a very famous um
diagram from element van essen showing
actually uh the visual cortical process
the visual processing hierarchy all the
way from retinal ganglion cells in the
retina all the way up to high level
visual areas um
and at the very top you see these two
areas entropy cortex and hippocampus and
these sit atop the visual sensory
hierarchy it turns out these sit on the
top of every sensory processing
hierarchy and these two are the areas
that we are most interested in uh when
we talk about spatial navigation so so
these are so intermittent cortex is a
high level association cortex it
combines information from all of the
different modalities and then it is the
main it is the soul cortical gateway
into hippocampus and hippocampus is
famously the structure um beautifully
rendered here um rainbow images from
jeff flickman's lab i'm showing um the
the gorgeous
organization uh of the structure and of
the neurons within it um in in the
rodent brain uh and it's famous uh for
um you know not just facial but also
non-spatial general autobiographical and
episodic memory
all right so um without further ado
let's um talk about some of the now
dynamics um and uh and states that
underlie these kinds of navigation
computations so in all of the things
that i'm going to show you today um the
the paradigm uh the behavior is very
very simple there isn't a task the
animal is just moving around freely
foraging in an open featureless square
box um looking for just uh you know
randomly dropped crumbles of food um of
course there's some spatial context
available in the bigger room so the
animal has a sense of orientation there
are some doors and windows outside in
the bigger world so and it can look over
the wall so that's always the the
scenario now the nature of these neural
recordings is to insert probes into the
animal's brain while the animal is
running around doing this um doing this
free behavior task um and so
simultaneously recorded units um are are
then collected together and lined up in
this way in this cell versus time raster
plot and to be able to then quantify or
say something about the structure of
these neural codes and the dynamics um
the the the uh the circuit level
characterization of the dynamics is to
bin all of the spikes from all the cells
at every given moment in time in a small
time bin um and collect the spike counts
for each cell and treat this if they're
n cells as an n-dimensional vector and
then plot it as a point in this
n-dimensional activity or state space
all right um and uh so this is the
general kind of
pictures that i'll be showing you so
luckily bruno has already told you about
this dedicated internal compass uh that
uh exists in mammalian brains this is
the head direction circuit in in
mammalia so bruno focused a bit on flies
i'll start telling you something about
mammals and i'll tell you about the
convergent evolution of it flies so this
is a circuit that uh you know
exists in the thalamus
this is
an input area to cortex
this uh area contains head direction
cells but also endurance cortex also
contains some hand direction cells so
we'll focus first on cells in the
thalamic area and um it's possible to
then look at these states-based um
structures that i i told you about how
we you know construct these state-space
structures and um and describe the
structure of these uh point clouds in
the state space so now the problem with
describing point clouds in this state
space is the state space is extremely
high dimensional so n is of the orders
of you know 2000 in this case of this
mammalian um circuit uh that contains uh
cells that indicate the animal's heading
direction a head direction and so it's
difficult in general to be able to say
much about structures in very high
dimensional spaces
and so a very useful tool if those
structures are non-trivial
topologically is to characterize the
structure using topological data
analysis methods including persistent
technology so we can use persistent
homology and um apply it to these um to
this point cloud of data from
this uh thalamic nucleus and what we
find is that um this circuit is well
characterized by a non-zero betting
number um uh h1 and um and nothing else
that's non-trivial and and therefore we
can conclude that the circuit is a ring
now because it's a ring we have the
luxury of now projecting this very high
dimensional state space structure into
um into three dimensions so we can have
a look and here i show you um the actual
data taken from 20 minutes of the animal
freely behaving and i should point out
that this behavior that i showed you of
free behavior the animals um actions are
quite rich it's moving around in two
dimensions it's running fast it's
running slow it's slowing down it's
grooming itself it's rearing up against
the walls of the environment and so on
so there's no sense in which the
behavior um is low dimensional but
nevertheless this circuit of about 2 000
neurons
has a dynamics which is extremely low
dimensional so that the states lie on
this simple one-dimensional ring-like
manifold
all right so um i think i think this is
uh you know pretty incredible there's a
lot more work that goes into showing
that you know these states seem to be
coding this one-dimensional variable and
not coding very much else um so if we've
now isolated um this one-dimensional
structure in the data uh what we can do
is we can further characterize
we can use the data set to actually try
to do completely unsupervised decoding
of what's going on in the brain so in
this case this is our manifold of states
this is a side view of that same ring
manifold and what we're doing is we're
fitting this ring manifold by a spline
um and now we can actually parameterize
the spline um
alongside um
you know in an isometric way so that
equal distances along this
neural state space correspond to equal
changes in this latent variable alpha
all right and now we can now colorize
the ring so every data point we can
color based on the value of the
parametrization here and now this gives
us a moment by moment decoding of the
state of the circuit um
in terms of this latent variable alpha
and so we can plot now this latent
variable alpha here in blue against the
physically measured head direction of
the animal shown in black up to an uh
you know a free choice of uh the origin
and the and whether it's clockwise or
counterclockwise you can see that these
two curves lie right on top of each
other so this
is a completely unsupervised way to
decode if you if you can characterize
the geometry and the topology of
manifolds then you can fit
splines of a matching dimension and
topology parameterize the splines and
then do unsupervised decoding so um in
other words what we can show is that the
circuit is a compass and it's nothing
but um compass coding so in response to
one of the questions that bruno had it
seems like in this case this seems to be
quite the exception to most um neurons
which tend to multiplex what they're um
encoding but in this case it seems to be
a very very factorized circuit that
seems to be coding just for a head
direction
all right so um
uh uh
let's move on to then uh discussing what
is the relationship between what i just
showed you which is a ring circuit in
the mammalian brain one thing i should
point out that in the mammalian brain
the the state space is a ring but it's
not clear if anatomically there is any
physical structure um uh uh that looks
like a ring uh on the other hand um the
fly circuit uh is uh actually physically
a ring and so these are the the neuropil
the the um
uh the the processes of the neurons that
connect in a physical ring like
structure and here if you image calcium
activity from these neurons this was
done by very geramin you can see that
there's a localized activity bump um in
this physical ring structure and this
activity bump moves around as the animal
moves around in space
so i have a movie here but it's not
playing so i'm gonna i'm gonna not take
the time to play the movie but um these
these are some pretty um striking um uh
images of the bum moving around as uh as
the visual um uh uh image showing to the
flag flows and the fly believes it's
turning
all right so that's the the compass
heading direction um at the same time uh
there is a downstream of the thalamic
nucleus uh in eternal cortex this area
contains another set of very striking
cells
many different cell types as a matter of
fact grid cells boundary cells and
landmark cells and i'll be primarily
telling you about grid cells
so um again same recording paradigm
animal is free moving and in black what
you can see here is the trajectory of
the animal uh as it moves around in
space and every red dot that you see
here all these dots are the spikes
emitted by a single cell that's being
recorded as the animal is doing this
behavior and you can see i think quite
clearly that these um these dots uh form
um clusters so they form uh you know
high density areas and in fact these
these clusters are arranged on the
vertices of a nice and regular
triangular lattice so here for your eye
to find your eye you can see this is a
regular triangular lattice and
of course there is no spatial lattice
drawn onto um onto this plane over here
where the animal is moving so internally
the animal is computing um that it has
reached this uh virtual vertex and uh
and and and therefore instructs the
sound of fire right so that's how the
cell has to know out of fire now these
um um cells have been found uh across
all the mammals in which they've been um
uh uh you know enriched undertone cortex
uh recordings have been made uh they're
found in
mice rats bats monkeys and humans um and
this is just one cell but it turns out
that if you look at all the cells that
are near each other in that same
brain area then different cells have the
same periodicity of the response
the same orientation of the lattice uh
uh and the only way in which they defer
is by the spatial phase of firing so
different cells may fire offset by rigid
translation in 2d but maintain the same
orientation and periods
um so if you move further along in the
in in the in in this in this region of
the brain and adrenal cortex um so this
demarcates the boundaries um in a
particular slice of brain so this red um
down to this white dashed area
moving um systematically along this long
axis
results in recordings where the grid
period is systematically changing
but it's not changing continuously in
terms of the um the grid cells these
grid cells have uh uh come in a cluster
with uh with a given period and then
there's a jump in the period um and so
on so the animal brain uh probably
contains a handful of periods maybe less
than 10 and the periods though
mysteriously span a range which is
rather small so it goes from about a
third of a meter for the smallest period
up to a meter and a half for the biggest
period and the reason i call this range
of periods rather small is because um in
comparison to the animals spatial
behaviors um uh
which uh go from like 100 meters to
about a kilometer per linear dimension
per day the animal goes looking for food
and is able to return to its own borough
over those distances nevertheless these
grid periods are rather small now these
cells maintain their spatial firing
patterns even when you turn out the
lights for some period of time
suggesting that again these animals are
computing these estimates of position
based on integration of the motion uh
cues that they receive from their own
self um uh vestibular uh sensation their
their you know self movement uh
proprioceptive signals from their
muscles and so on
all right so how does one explain how
these um cells might arise so um it
turns out that the the the mechanism uh
for uh the for for this uh functionality
and for the tuning of these grid cells
um is actually rather simple and it's
similar to the mechanism that bruno
mentioned for uh ring networks so the
the principle is one of um touring
instability so pattern formation uh and
and velocity coupling so if we consider
a cortical sheet and let's consider that
set of neurons right in the center there
and let's suppose that they all interact
um through in a competitive interaction
where
they excite themselves locally but then
inhibit everything in a ring around them
um and so by chance if a group of
neurons is more active than
average it'll suppress all the neurons
in the sheet around it and then um these
neurons at the periphery are going to be
disinhibited and they might become
active so this set becomes active and
then um the neurons at the intersection
of those two inhibitory uh uh bands is
maximally disinhibiting this one becomes
active and so on until you get a whole
pattern so the the the stable states of
the of this competitive interaction of
this dynamics in the cortical sheet is
irregular um triangular lattice patterns
and in fact all of these patterns
related by uh shifts in the phase
continuous shifts in the phase are
equivalent fixed points for the dynamics
and of course if you move by one period
in this direction you're back to the
same pattern and if you move by one
period in this direction you're back to
the same pattern so that defines a
continuous manifold of fixed points that
has periodicity in two dimensions and so
that corresponds to a simple torus um so
the prediction is that the state space
of these units should uh you know the
whole circuit of neurons is about 10 000
neurons presumably that form this one
module of cells with the same
periodicity should uh the state should
lie on the surface of a torus and then
the mechanism for
updating the states of these neurons as
a function of the animal's movement in
the physical world is to couple this
pattern's phase with physical movements
in the world so if the animal moves
physically in the world if there's a way
to couple the the phase of this pattern
and cause it to flow in proportion to
the animal movements that then will
produce the kind of
spatial tuning so periodic spatial
tuning
as a function of physical space so the
animal moves if the pattern flows a
neuron will be active and inactive and
active again and so on and so on would
then reproduce this kind of dynamics so
um these models are called continuous
attractor models of grid cells that have
been rather successful
in
predicting
subsequent discoveries uh made uh in in
in the in the entertainment cortex uh
because the initial recordings uh
involved recording of single cells or a
couple of cells at a time however these
models are network models and so it
means that they make instantaneously a
bunch of predictions about uh the
population response of the circuit for
example that the state space should be
um toroidal um and and that the states
should you should form a set of fixed
points that is a taurus so the ten
thousand dimensional state space should
nevertheless contain only a two
dimensional stable torus and moreover
the cell cell relationships like here
because a pair of cells that separated
by uh one period in the connectivity
should always be active
exactly in phase whereas two cells that
are separated by half of the width of
the inhibitory surround
should be exactly active in counter
phase and so this relationship according
to this
turing pattern formation picture these
cell cell relationships should be
invariant and stable across environments
across time um and so in fact
that is what has been found so even in
different environments of different
shapes and geometries even though the
spatial tuning of these neurons may
become deformed but nevertheless the
cells that relationships of cells
remains invariant um when you record
animals in 1d environments so along
linear 1d tracks the spatial responses
look not like grid cells they look maybe
multiply peaked but not periodic and
these are two cells simultaneously
recorded but it turns out that
it's possible to um predict uh that
these one-dimensional responses uh
the next peaks can be predicted by
simply fitting a slice through uh
underlying 2d
lattice pattern in fact you can predict
then the two-dimensional phase offset
you can record these two one-dimensional
responses and then predict what the
slice angle is through this
two-dimensional lattice and you can in
fact get a 2d prediction of the phase
offset that you would expect to see
between the cell pair
in two dimensions and then you can go
and record these cells in two dimensions
and test whether that phase offset is
correct and in fact it seems to be
correct so in other words in one day
these cells have a quasi periodic or
quality crystal like responses uh but um
they're and they're predicted by slices
through a regular 2d grid and most
recently as bruno pointed out
simultaneous uh recordings of multiple
grid cells at the same time from the
same animal have allowed us uh the
community to characterize that the grid
cell states are indeed localized to
a 2d taurus
regardless of the environment and a cl
across waking and sleep
okay so just to summarize the general
mechanisms for um memory in general in
these circuits and for integration of
velocity signals across the ring network
and across the head direction and across
the grid network is um is that there's
strong connectivity laterally in the in
in the circuit to create persistent
stable states for memory um and the
tuning of head direction and grid cells
to analog variables is well modeled as
emerging from pattern formation in
networks with a continuous symmetry this
validates um you know a line of
beautiful theoretical
work and predictions starting from omari
in 1977 and of course hopfield um in the
80s 1984 and um and specifically for
continuous attractor networks um seminal
work from the early from the mid 90s um
and um these form patterns uh
act because they form uh fixed points um
they act as these robust memory states
and his representational states
so i'd like to turn now to the question
of
their their coding theoretical
properties right so one perplexing thing
is so these grid cells seem to be um
representing cartesian space uh
two-dimensional uh representation and
updating the positional estimate based
on integration of um velocity in the
world but why have a non-local and a
periodic code for this variable which is
um the location of an animal in an you
know which is an aperiodic and local
variable so this brings um us to the
question of the coding theoretic
question um uh
of why have these bizarre grid cells so
i like to uh analogize uh what you see
in the grid code for position as instead
of walking into a room and seeing a
clock like a conventional 12 hour clock
you walk in and instead see a wall of
clocks
which have different periods
and the periods are all very short so
these are instead of these being 12
hours this is 9 minutes 10 minutes and
so on up to 17 minutes right so you just
get these um you know you get these uh
uh these these short period clocks and a
bunch of them representing um uh time
and so and and the reason this is
analogous to the grid code is because
the grid uh cells in one module all
represent position x as simply a phase
modulo the lattice geometry uh and so uh
or we can think about it as x mod lambda
one over lambda one which is the period
of the first lattice if we're thinking
in one dimension and and so on and so if
there are n different lattices or
periods or modules then you have just a
set of n distinct phases representing
the position um x and once again as i
pointed out these are
all very short uh small numbers small
periods compared to the ranges over
which you would care to represent
position
so just to cut to the chase and you know
and and tell a long story just you know
um uh you know quickly um uh what is
interesting about this code is as you
saw um your decomposing position into uh
a set of different phases uh
modulo uh a bunch of different you know
small periods and so if they're in
different periods and again we're
thinking about one dimensional space for
example and each grid network being a
random dimensional representation if
you've got n phases then um the code the
coding space now not the dynamical state
space but the coding space is now an
n-dimensional torus um where each phase
is now uh uh it is now a circular
variable and so um we we can think about
as you know position changes then the
the the coding in this in this coding
space is just a line that's evolving uh
on this n-dimensional torus and so in
this case um you know you both uh phase
one and phase two are evolving um and of
course when you come back around in
phase one you haven't quite wrapped
around in phase two because they have
different periods and so on so this
actually defines a space filling curve
and it turns out this space filling
curve has um some very beautiful
properties including a nice interleaving
property where as you can see over here
from the zoom in um so so this color
scheme represents position and you can
see that nearby coding lines actually
represent very far away positions so in
other words there's an interleaving of
you know um that you know similar
positions are very maximally well
separated from one another all the blues
and then um and then and or all the you
know dark reds and then um nearby um
coding lines represent very far away
positions so it turns out that um you
get two properties so the first property
is from the space filling curve the fact
is that with linearly many neurons n um
are modules which is proportional to the
number of neurons you get exponentially
many distinct spatial coding states but
the interleaving property gives you
beautiful error correcting coding
properties and so it's possible if you
decimate your coding space then you get
well separated coding lines and it's
possible to do error correction um and
so um okay so um it's possible to then
use like this very high capacity coding
as many distinct like we can think about
each of these like local vicinities or
local coding lines as sort of um you
know
local coding for a local uh environment
and we can think about you know some of
these other uh coding lines like this
yellow one as uh encoding of a very
different environment right and you now
have a local metric map uh but a bunch
of distinct local metric maps for many
different environments so that's one way
to use this very large um state space
there's many other beautiful properties
if you have modular arithmetic which is
this you know this modulo phases um it
turns out that you can update all of the
phases in parallel without doing the
kind of serial addition and carry
forward that you have to do in fixed
base number systems so that means that
it's parallel to it's possible to do
non-serial parallel updating across
moduli which leads to a big speed up and
there's also no information carry across
modules so you don't have to have one
module communicate to the other um no
long distance connectivity and still be
able to
run this you know across module
cooperative encoding of exponentially
large positions so it's a very
interesting and beautiful code and so
just in a nutshell then um you know it's
like taking this you know coding line if
you're thinking about 1d positions um
and then um represent you know uh
wrapping this coding line around as a
space filling sort of curve in into this
you know high dimensional space of all
the neural activities but it's a sparse
enough coding line that nevertheless if
you've got a ball of noise around
each state it's possible to then error
correct by mapping to the nearest region
of the coding line and then be able to
recover
accurately the estimate of position in
the shannon sense all right so the key
features of the grid cell code are that
you can get exponentially many states
with
many neurons um there's this you know
interleaving property which is important
for error control and finally these
coding states are you know it's an
algebraic code um the code word for x
plus the code word for y equals the code
word for x plus y so although there are
other um
uh exponential capacity uh coding you
know like random codes and so on but
these code words are not merely just
words like and bob but they actually
have this algebraic property um and most
recently i'd like to point to a recent
work by um alexander's
globe and colleagues um that was just
posted to the archive showing that not
only is the grid code a strong error
correcting code in the shannon sense but
it's also
makes possible fault tolerant computing
where you basically have errors end to
end with no noise free um error
correcting readout at the very end so
this i think is um is an important
property and could have important
ramifications for analog computing
neuromorphic computing as well as on
quantum computing
all right so that's my coding summary uh
can i just ask if i have um four more
minutes given the delay in the start or
should i just stop at this point
um we're actually running a few minutes
over ella is there is there a quick
summary of the this this is a reasonable
this is a reasonable stopping point um
so i am just going to um i had one more
small story but i i think i will just
give you the the conclusion of that
small story and then i will stop at that
point so the final the final story is
that um
the final story that i wanted to tell is
that um this this network um the network
i've been showing you throughout
consisting of you know grid cells um
hydration cells uh and then projecting
to um another set of cells that i didn't
tell you about place cells which is
going to be this last part of the story
um where the grid cells have sort of
content-free states so we can think
about grid cells as being
low-dimensional
fixed content-free um states that then
um map to place cells which have uh
which include content uh because they
build associations between these
abstract internal coordinate um
representations of where the animal is
and combine that with landmark
information or other information about
what is out there in the world so this
kind of circuit it turns out
is capable of building uh a an
associative memory that does not show
the kind of memory clips that are seen
in conventional um
auto associative memory networks like
the hopfield network and um this is a
very interesting property given that the
hippocampus is also believed to be a
general episodic memory network and not
just a spatial memory buffer and so i
don't have too much time to tell you
about this but i can say that if you are
interested then um please look at a work
by sharma at all in icml 2022. um okay
so uh the the analogy that you know i
would like to leave you with is to think
about this enter rhino hippocampal
circuit much more generally than just
spatial coding and to think about them
as a clothesline where the grid cell
system provides these structured states
like clothes like the clothing line and
then
the world experience from the world now
uh consists of um
items that can be clipped to this rigid
low-dimensional structure to build a
pretty flexible
memory system that overcomes the
capacity limits
as well as memory cliff behaviors of
conventional associative memory networks
so at this point i will thank you all
for your attention and
thank the many wonderful
brilliant students uh who have made this
work um possible and have contributed um
many insights to all of it so thanks
again
[Applause]
fantastic thank you
uh maybe one
quick question
um
uh you mentioned error error correction
and also unsupervised learning um
do those two seem to be at odds um
with each other it seems like to to to
do error um error correction you have to
know the ground truth the ground truth
um can you just elaborate on that a bit
so these are um you know like this is
error correction in the sense of error
correcting codes so these are not
referenced to an external state so this
is just um so this is the you know this
is like shannon error correcting coding
theory where you have um coding states
coding states can be corrupted by noise
um so normally in coding theory you
might think about communication through
a noisy channel in this case if we're
talking about memory circuits or just
representational circuits it's just um
you know the channel is just time
or the chat right or the channel is
computation and um you get you can get
corruption of the states um with the
noise um in in that in that channel and
these uh coding uh uh you know these
coding schemes permit you know error
correcting like self error correcting
dynamics uh equipped with an appropriate
internal decoder right so i guess in
that sense it doesn't require an
external ground truth it just requires
you know erasure of noise
all right thanks very much hila that was
a really fascinating talk again
pleasure
[Applause]
all right and the last speaker before
the break is uh sham kakade uh